der bundeskanzler ist seit zwei minuten
nach acht hier im
verteidigungsausschuss und dort steht
der rede und antwort sie haben es
angesprochen marie agnes strack
zimmermann von der fdp die vorsitzende
dieses ausschusses hatte am 27
april vorgesehen dass der kanzler hier
rede und antwort stehen soll am 28 april
nachdem der kanzler diesen termin
abgesagt hatte hat der bundestag
beschlossen schwere waffen zu liefern
und in der tat kann man darüber
diskutieren was deutschland jetzt schon
geliefert hat die panzerhaubitze sie ist
noch nicht geliefert und auch dieser
gebhard panzer ist noch lange nicht in
der ukraine also schwere waffen
fehlanzeige also die einladung ist ja
ausgesprochen worden von vortrag
zimmermann sie ist ja von der fdp will
sagen sie ist ja irgendwie auch
involviert die fdp in diese regierung
beteiligt an dieser regierung weist
heißen das ganze politisch ist das
politisch ein bisschen unberechenbar was
da heute passiert
nein die wogen haben sich ja
mittlerweile geglättet ich habe es
gesagt der bundestag hat diesen
beschluss gefasst und in der tat war das
vorgehen der fdp politikerin stark
zimmermann damals von den beiden ampel
tragenden parteien spd und grüne massiv
kritisiert worden den kanzler hier so
vorzuladen aber dass der bundeskanzler
gelegentlich in ausschüsse geht und
heute hier im verteidigungsausschuss
rede und antwort steht das ist nicht
ganz so ungewöhnlich es geht unter
anderem heute auch um das 100 milliarden
sondervermögen wie es immer so schön
heißt und natürlich haben die
abgeordneten fragen an den bundeskanzler
und welche fragen er den hut habe ich
den verteidigungspolitischen sprecher
der cdu/csu florian hahn vor dieser
sitzung gefragt der bundeskanzler hat
heute die chance man im
verteidigungsausschuss darzulegen
woher eigentlich der eindruck kommt das
ist eine große diskrepanz gibt zwischen
einerseits dem was die bundesregierung
angekündigt beispielsweise in der
unterstützung der ukraine und was
tatsächlich ankommt und diese diskrepanz
entsteht wenn man sich mit ukrainischen
spitzenvertretern unterhält die entsteht
wenn man die entsprechenden listen ein
sieht die im bundestag unter geheim
ausgelegt sind
denn das passt irgendwie nicht zusammen
sieben panzerhaubitzen das 40 für laien
jetzt nicht so viel an und das system
gepard eines der kompliziertesten
systeme was die bundeswehr hätte
anbieten können ist dass der anteil
deutschlands an großgerät na ja es wäre
schön wenn der geburt tatsächlich zur
verfügung stehen würde aber
offensichtlich hat ja auch hier die
bundesregierung etwas versprochen was
tatsächlich in den sternen steht nämlich
offensichtlich versprochen bevor man
sich darüber sicher sein konnte ob das
mit der ausbildung auch bei dem gepard
klappen kann auch das vor allem aber mit
der munition klappen kann und jetzt bis
heute ein großes fragezeichen
die ukraine hat bis heute keinen
geparden und es ist auch keiner in sicht
sofern könnte sich das als großes
eigentor herausstellen und da fragt man
warum man überhaupt mit diesem
waffensystem sich beschäftigt haben und
nicht mit anderen herr kiesewetter aus
ihrer fraktion hat gesagt der gepard ist
überhaupt kein problem der wird im
november geliefert werden bis dahin ist
überhaupt kein problem munition zu
beschaffen
denn die schweiz liefert die nicht aber
es gibt noch ein werk in italien
diskutieren ich auch manchmal völlig an
der sache vorbei
also an der sache vorbei diskutieren was
andere kollegen sagen das brauche ich
nicht sozusagen kommentieren aber ich
kann nur sagen dass de facto bis heute
wieder ein gepard da ist noch munition
und die ukraine auch sich aktuell gegen
die russische föderation als
investor wehren muss und ob das im
november reicht da manchmal ein großes
fragezeichen also es geht jetzt um
konkrete hilfe so schnell wie möglich
ukraine und tatsächlich für hilfe die
auch wirklich hilft und da war der
gepard glaube ich ein falsches system
wir müssen wir darüber reden was denn
tatsächlich panzerhaubitze ist eine
hilfe auf sieben stück so eine richtige
verstärkung sind weil ich auch mal ein
fragezeichen allein das kleine land
estland liefert acht panzerhaubitzen wir
sieben als deutlich größere nation muss
man sich da mal eine frage stellen und
man muss sich die frage stellen warum
eigentlich der mann nicht schon lange
geliefert ist denn hier sind nach
industrieangaben 100 sofort verfügbar
mit ausreichender munition also viele
fragezeichen ja was ist da eigentlich
los in der deutschen bundesregierung
gestern hat die britische
außenministerin gesagt wir müssen viel
mehr viel schneller waffen liefern und
die deutsche außenminister hat er bei
dem gleichen gipfel gesagt war sehr
defensiv und hat gesagt warten wir mal
ab da ging es zum beispiel um
kampfflugzeuge scheint wohl überhaupt
nicht zur diskussion zu stehen in der
bundesregierung andere länder
diskutieren das offen warum ist
deutschland also defensiv also wir
erleben nicht nur seit ausbruch des
krieges sondern auch schon vorher in der
ukraine krise eine sehr zurückhaltend
sehr zögerliche bundesregierung
das hat sich dann verbal an mancher
stelle etwas anders dann entwickelt aber
de facto tatsächlich resultate ist es so
und es ist vor allem auch die
wahrnehmung bei unseren nachbarn wenn
sie sich mit beispielsweise unseren
baltischen partnern unterhalten die er
direkt an der grenze zu weißrussland
oder zur russischen föderation selbst
stehen und sich schon seit jahren extrem
mit vorkommen muss man sagen die machen
auch stellen auch fragen und sind
einigermaßen
ernüchtert über die zurückhaltung der
bundesrepublik deutschland hier würden
sich die partner tatsächlich in
deutschland wünschen das wirklich führt
das ganz vorne es wenn es darum geht auf
der einen seite die ukraine zu helfen
und auf der anderen seite die partner
unter die arme zu greifen und zu sagen
wir stehen ganz fest an eurer seite und
das nicht nur mit worten sondern auch
mit taten man sagt da kannst du ja immer
wir müssen da aufpassen dass wir nicht
kriegsteilnehmer werden diese defensive
haltung der bundesregierung gibt eine
neue umfrage wird von einem guten
drittel der deutschen geteilt natürlich
gibt es viele die angst haben dass man
in den krieg verwickelt wird
selbstverständlich aber die entscheidung
ob wir verwickelt werden oder nicht
liegt nicht bei uns sondern liegt bei
dem aggressor und wir sehen dass der
aggressor putin ist und dass er vor
allem überhaupt kein interesse hat an
irgend einer verhandlungslösung alle
verhandlungsangebote von den ukrainern
wurden mehr oder weniger zurückgewiesen
alle auch sagen ich mal möglichkeiten
sich irgendwo
bei einem gemeinsamen punkt zu treffen
wurden zurückgewiesen russland stellt
nur maximalforderungen und ist weiter
unerbittlich im kampf gegen die ukraine
um die ukraine tatsächlich zu besiegen
und zu unterjochen ganz kurzen noch wenn
finnland und vielleicht auch schweden
demnächst an
nato-mitglieder werden ist das nicht
eine immense zusatz gefährdung weil sich
putin dann sicherlich sehr provoziert
fühlt und 1300 kilometer ist eine
verdoppelung der grenze zu russland ich
glaube man muss es andersherum sehen
wenn man sieht dass finnland und
schweden eigentlich immer aus absoluter
überzeugung neutral waren und sich
offensichtlich jetzt als neutrale
staaten so bedroht fühlen dass sie sagen
das einzige was uns am ende tatsächlich
helfen kann ist eine nato-mitgliedschaft
eine mitgliedschaft in einem
verteidigungsbündnis einem nicht
aggressiven bündnissen oder merck
verteidigungsbündnis dann sieht man wie
schlimm die lage ist und die starke vor
allem euro unserer europäischen partner
die bedrohung auch tatsächlich
einschätzen ich glaube dass das manchmal
in deutschland nämlich ganz angekommen
ist
der bundeskanzler hat ist ja gestern
noch einmal klar gemacht deutschland
unterstützt den wunsch der finnen in die
nato zu kommen und das werden sicherlich
auch die anderen nato ländern und ist
dennoch dauert das sicherlich ein
bisschen bevor finnland und auch
wahrscheinlich schweden der
nato-mitglieder sein werden und das ist
natürlich eine zusätzliche gefährdung
für diese beiden länder wolfgang
hellmich ist der verteidigungspolitische
sprecher der spd bundestagsfraktion und
auch mit ihm sprach ich vor dieser
sitzung zunächst auch über seine
erwartungshaltung was wird der kanzler
hier heute den abgeordneten sagen können
erstmal bin ich dankbar dafür dass er
das tut das hat mir schon lange nicht
mehr und ich glaube es ist ein zeichen
des hohen respekt vor der arbeit des
parlamentes noch ein zeichen dafür dass
wir in dieser sehr schwierigen situation
auch zwischen regierung und parlament
und gerade dem verteidigungsausschuss
sehr eng zusammen arbeiten und ich
erwarte mir eigentlich von der
empa aussagen dazu beginnt es denn
eigentlich weiter wie sind die aussagen
zu verstehen er wisse satz zu verstehen
die ukraine darf den krieg nicht
verlieren und putin darf den krieg nicht
gewinnen sie vermissen wir das terrain
mit welchen zielen geht man denn da rein
und wie verhält sich der westen an der
stelle weil ein zentrales an sinn war ja
und das ist ja auch richtig dass der
westen gemeinsam und geschlossen
auftreten muss in der deutschland eine
starke stimme warum tun uns eigentlich
so schwer mit der waffenlieferung gerade
bei schweren waffen 7 panzerhaubitzen
das ist jetzt nicht die welt und dann
vor allen dingen der gap hat der in
monaten erst ausgeliefert werden kann
ein kompliziertes system bisher noch gar
keine schweren waffen geliefert und
jetzt hat gerade die britische
außenministerium gefordert dass alle
jetzt noch mehr reinhauen müssen und
mehr waffen liefern müssen das hat ja
frau baerbock etwas abgekommen hat also
was ist da los in der deutschen
bundesregierung also wir müssen das
liefern was brauchbares und was richtig
ist und was die ukraine auch brauchen
können
und diese systeme stehen sich in
vielfältiger form zur verfügung deshalb
ist es richtig dass gestern die
ausbildung an der panzerhaubitze in idar
oberstein begonnen hat
und das geht nicht von heute auf morgen
es sind komplexe systeme und deshalb
kommt es darauf an denn jetzt aber mit
dem nötigen tempo dieser ausbildung auch
zu vollziehen und damit die
waffensysteme mit den ausgebildeten
personal zur verfügung stehen aber
heimlich form liefern wir nicht zum
beispiel marder oder leopard 1 die
industrie sagt ist es ein relativ
einfaches für sie die möglichst schnell
zu liefern also die waffensysteme sind
zum teil noch komplexer also man setzt
nicht einfach eine mannschaft in leopard
und sagt firma los sondern gehören
schützenpanzer dazu da würden
panzergrenadiere dazu man kann nicht
einfach ein kanzler losschicken und
deshalb ist es glaube ich richtig zu
sehen was will die ukraine haben die
voran jetzt hat ja auch gesagt hat sie
wollen den leopard kann aber ein
schützenpanzer brauchen sie für den
einsatz schon um nämlich ihre eigenen
truppen zu schützen in dem gericht vor
allem ob gegen einflüsse von oben dazu
braucht man konzerte fahrzeuge
die anträge die hier offensichtlich vor
genau weiß ich es nicht wirken in den
bundessicherheitsrat mich rein aber ich
gehe davon aus dass die zusagen der der
autoindustrie sich auch zum beispiel um
die ausbildung zum beispiel gepard auch
entsprechend umgesetzt werden müssen nun
wurde ja viel hin und her diskutiert der
kanzler müsse nach kiel fahren ist das
wirklich der entscheidende faktor der
wäre es nicht viel entscheidender
tatsächlich zu definieren was können wir
jetzt tun wie lange wird diese bedrohung
voraussichtlich anhalten und müssen wir
als deutsche in als lead nation nicht
tatsächlich auch bei waffenlieferungen
vorangehen also ich glaube symbole sind
wichtig ja aber
es kommt nur darauf an dass zu
organisieren was zu tun ist und ich
glaube das was der kanzler bin ich das
richtig sehe im moment tut ist in der
tat die entscheidung und im westlichen
bündnis ganz wesentlich voranzutreiben
aber sicher um die fragen der jungen zu
kümmern das ist auch seine aufgabe dass
die führungsaufgaben deutschlands an der
stelle die wir da auch wahrnehmen wie
auch von der bundesregierung
wahrgenommen wird und nämlich das zu
erreichen dass mit den bündnispartnern
zusammen die alle keine wie heißt es so
schön schwere waffen geliefert haben ist
jetzt eine gemeinsame haltung in der
nato dass man da keine schweren
gepanzerten
fahrzeuge mit den langen rohren im
großen kaliber liefert die neue
situation auch gar nicht gar nicht
sinnvoll wären also an der stelle das
nötige zu tun zu organisieren
sich so an symbol fragen sage ich mal
aufzuhängen ist jetzt zum besuch in kiew
das was man braucht oder nicht
da kann man sehr unterschiedlicher
meinung zu sein aber ich glaube die
situation im tier selber und die
gespräche die es mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten gegeben hat und dies auch
zwischen dem kanzlerin ihm regelmäßig
gibt sind wesentlich wirkungsvoller